veramente 20 minuti da tifosa ritardo
finalmente deciso e faccio il colore
sterzata d'aria nuova no ma con tutto
diamo noi non li voglio tagliare
io voglio sfruttare guardi faccio vedere
e poi la cosa mi ha lasciato più
spiazzata dipinte donato è il gusto che
mi lascia la star e trova così così
giusto con la punta questo quali piace
molto però forse troppo biondo questo
sprint piacciono si son bellissima se da
crociera foto se la toglie
simo ciao amore strobel parrucchiere la
lista stimandola fosse passata di me se
ti piace apre sincero allora la linea
noi facciamo oggi
allora io do pensato liscio un po adesso
cioè boccolosi ma senza il bocolo ci
voleva proprio
e poi sembra neanche che li abbiamo
tagliati no no no finalmente si è
sposata alla samp dai
non ci siamo tutti di luci perché
insomma voglio la pelle un po più
piallata che sarebbe molto ma molto
vediamo è mai simile al mi volevo
comunque cambiare se mare in coppa privè
belli i parrucchieri che stanno
guardando questo video si possono fare
caselli per sfruttarle perché se noi
chiediamo di tagliarli spuntare
appuntamento a girare scusami un attimo
mentre ho chiesto l'abilità di kim
kardashian perché a me lo stanno bene
come lei forse perché non sai chi
incapace vestite secondo me poteva fare
di più ondulato senza onde non so se hai
capito milionari è un appuntamento molto
importante arriva per i fatti
ai miracoli non si parli mirato rifarli
a quella belen
passa un de martino uno così cosa vuol
dire che sono uguale a prima vista per i
capelli di un centimetro e mezzo ma sai
questo perché se questo perché perché
non mi guardi che come prima ovviamente
poiché sono frangia lunga e io allora
non save ieri non ha decorato york sono
bravissima però sempre detto però io
conosco i miei capelli non ti voglio
insegnare ai miei idee si chiama così
sul sì io volevo il ciuffo ed ha tanto
però se tu fai confine con quadrifoglio
pare un po più gonfio nè mastrangelo
onda vuol dire che si faccia capire
tutto un pranzo di le prende
adesso come faccio a me piace più ma
meco cresce sono 25 25 ago una piega ma
stiamo scherzando
andiamo quadrati leccesi la facevano 6
euro ragazzi c'è veramente grazie grazie
grazie